a lot of politicians will vote
libertarian if they think that's how
they remain politicians
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with recent TV and
today we're talking with norm singleton
he's the vice president for policy at
the campaign for liberty norm you were a
long time legislative aide to
congressman Ron Paul Ron Paul's also the
founder of campaign for liberty tell us
what the organization's mission is
campaign for liberty is a 501 C 4 for
those of you who don't obsess over the
tax code that basically means that we're
a grassroots lobbying organization that
works to put pressure on Congress and
state and local governments to support
Liberty our signature issues are audit
the Fed we are also been very involved
in fighting the Patriot Act fighting the
Transportation Security Administration
opposing the national internet sales tax
and Eve arif I and national ID cards and
these are all extensions and kind of
embellishments of the issues that Ron
Paul was interested in how is the audit
the Fed going this is one of those
things that is wildly pop you know 15
years ago you couldn't even say if you
were talking about auditing the Fed
people would ask you to remove your tin
foil hat and leave quietly now how many
I mean the audit bills to audit the Fed
have hundreds of sponsors or co-sponsors
in Congress what's going to happen with
that well we're hoping that this year we
confer this Congress rather we could
finally persuade Harry Reid to allow a
Senate floor vote on audit the Fed
that's was the problem last year we did
have a floor vote in the house and it
passed fairly overwhelmingly and
surprisingly bipartisan but Reid has
continued to block it there might be a
leverage point coming up next year or
later this year when Bernanke Ben
Bernanke steps down as chairman and
President Obama has to fill that post
which could give us a leverage to force
free to give us a vote
you know some of the issues that
campaign for liberty is is involved in
our things that are you know explicitly
libertarian about limiting the size
scope and spending of government I mean
you know all of them are but what's
interesting is that when you talk about
things like you know state surveillance
of that avera fire creating a national
ID card bringing the TSA the
Transportation Security Administration a
heel these are issues that play very
well across the political spectrum have
you guys had much contact or impact on
either Democratic politicians or people
on the left that normally don't suit up
with the with libertarians we have I
mean are we have members in all 50
states so we have members in various
congressional districts and there are
Democrats who are good on civil
liberties issues like Ron Wyden who we
are willing to work with our Democrats
who are good on audit the Fed I mean
even Bernie Sanders the socialist has
some interest in at least Federal
Reserve transparency so and we're
willing to work with people on single
issue coalition's across the board some
surprising coalition's on for example
agriculture farm policy you find
greenies who you wouldn't think that
someone like me would be in the same
room with but for different for maybe
four different reasons we both support
ending subsidies to big to big AG
Obamacare the Affordable Care Act is you
know starting the enrollment period is
going to start on october first what are
you guys doing to combat that we are
have alerted our members to support
defunding obamacare right now that looks
like a very very uphill climb but we're
hopeful that at least by putting
pressure on Congress to do something
that there will be something coming up
like a delay of Obamacare which perhaps
some red state Democrats may be
interested in supporting you know you
obviously you were in Congress or you
worked in a congressional office for
years we're already we're a month away
from the
you know end of a fiscal year we which
didn't have a budget we've got no
possibility of a budget for the next
year so what has to happen for the
budget process to get back into into
working shape again one thing might be
the government just is too big and it's
too unwieldy and with all the moving
parts all the special interests it's
just not feasible to expect Congress to
pass 13 appropriation bills maybe we
should try to whittle it down to where
there's only six ten appropriation bills
you know I'd like to see one very small
appropriation bill passed but since
we're not going to get there soon may
that might be be the problem it would be
nice in terms of being able to have more
effect on actual policy to get back to
the days when Congress spent the summer
both bodies passing 13 appropriation
bills they went to conference committee
in the fall and then they passed each
one one at a time because that that
would allow for a process where
individual members congressmen senators
could actually influence the process and
maybe we could get some reductions in
spending though is that a lack of
leadership on the part of the Democrats
and the Republicans or is it the
president's fault that they are not
being held accountable to do I mean the
most basic function of government which
is to say how much money you're going to
spend I think I think at first it was
just the just a result of the sort of
weird weird partisan dynamic that led to
these yearly showdowns between the
president and congress and it somehow
over time just became standard operating
procedure it's it's weird no nobody on
either side in either party in either
branch actually seems to think there's
anything dysfunctional now about waiting
till the fall to talk about next year's
budget and then waiting till three weeks
before Christmas before starting to
write a gigantic omnibus budget or
artsy are to be voted on the week before
Christmas well I guess it's a good time
to give gifts right if nothing else and
that seems to be what Congress is mostly
probably you know a couple people as a
final question a number of people have
been talking about how there's a
libertarian moment going on you know and
certainly it seems for the first time
you've been in this business for a long
time you have people like Rand Paul you
have mike lee at people like Justin
Amash and Thomas Massie a number of
Republicans at least who are calling
themselves libertarians are we in a
libertarian moment and if so what what
needs to happen next to really lock in
any meaningful reduction in the size
scope and spending of government we're
either in a libertarian moment or were
just at the at the tipping point to to
get to a libertarian moment right now we
are leaving with Senator Paul and
Congressman Amash and Congressman Massie
that obviously they're providing great
leadership in the house our institutions
seem to be flourishing as never before
clearly the only political with it with
the collapse of mainstream conservative
ideologies support among the young
people and the continuing
disillusionment that the Obama that the
Obama youth of 2008 and 2000-2012 are
having libertarianism is the only
political philosophy that seems to have
any type of appeal among young people as
congressman paul says what needs to be
done is continuing to so for those of us
who aren't directly in politics is to
spread the message and work to mobilize
people to keep putting pressure on our
politicians to move in the direction
towards paul and massey and Amash
because a lot of politicians will vote
libertarian if they think that's how
they remain politicians i hate to break
it to you Nick but sometimes people in
office of both parties do just vote
because they think that's the popular
way to vote campaign for liberty is
participating in a big
libertarian kind of hootenanny coming up
tell us about L pack and where we can
get more information about l pac 2013
will be September 19th through the 21st
at the westfield marriott in chantilly
virginia you can get information at our
website campaign for liberty calm among
the speakers will be both dr. Paul's
congressman Amash congressman Massey
well thank you very much i want to thank
norm singleton he's a vice president for
policy a campaign for liberty for
talking with reason TV today Thank You
norm thank you for reason TV I'm
Nicholas